Um, the next list we're going to be discussing
[inaudible]. Wow. I guess we're just going in the water now. All right. Okay.
Who, I can't remember when I've last updated this. Cause I stopped updating my
mouse and I moved over to, you can see what the most recent and I moved over to
kids, Sue. So it depends if kids who is also updating this, but, um,
this is going to be my teenage, uh,  tastes I'm guessing. So
I can, I can tell this is your teenage days because like, I don't know
. In a past episode you talked so much about a Kira
and you've given it an eight out of 10.
What would you give it now? I'll give you like a six, a six
gave I can make a kill. You curious,
is it, is it really low? I'm just curious. Yeah. What is it?
What'd you get three years. What would you rate it today?
If I asked you to rate, I can make a kill, like to two to that bad.
Yeah. I would also give it. It's pretty bad. It's pretty. Okay.
You gave it a four. You gave it a four. Okay. Okay, good, good. Yeah.
Teenage me. I tastes okay. I can't make a kill.
Was one of those shows where I thought it was awful.
And then all the comments were the mangas better. The mangas better.
Trust me guys. The Mongols better.
So it was one of those few times why called them on their bluff? Right?
I called the Monga. Rita's on their bluff and I read the marker up to the end.
And I'm just like, this is just the same. Just elongates. I mean,
everyone was complaining about the animated only ending of a comment. Go kill.
But the Monga is like equally as edgy, but it just, it just elongates.
It just has a different ending and it's, it's,
it's equally as bad in my Al the nurse. A zero.
You gave it a six season. What? A six and, and season two or six season two.
Come on. It's infinitely worse than season one. Season one,
zero season one is actually like pretty decent, I think. Yeah.
You still good of stuff about album nosy I'll know, zero season one.
I don't remember why she maybe finished both of them at the same time.
Like you may be off with the shaver because,
because I remember I would know season one being pretty interesting and then it
was like, it was, it was great.
And then the cliff hanger season ending happened and it was just like, Holy.
This is super interesting. And then season two,
just kind of on everything that season one session became like Kira tones and
stuff in the garden. Yeah, I know. I know.
I know this is like teenage God's list because you came buckets Testo and eight
dude. Okay. Okay. I still stand by that. Yeah, it is.
It is when you also gave season two and eight as well.
It does not as good as season one. I've never watched back.
What's back test about it's just like a, it's like a comedy,
like kind of trashy, like romance itch,
to be honest. I like it.
I thought it was pretty good Schuman ambassador for domestic girlfriend.
That's right up his phone.
It was like one of the first comedy anime that actually made me laugh.
And I didn't think was generic. And now
I look back, I think, yeah, it was probably pretty generic. I don't know.
Like I look at the art style and I'm just like,
this is premium mid two thousands. Animate is nothing interesting.
Uh, back in. Oh, a 10 as well. Yeah. Yup. Yup. I think we all get back
on my list. I don't know what that's why,
that's why I'm curious to see what your three by threes are because that's,
that's where that's where like the real personality test comes in. Hold on.
I gotta ask that. Marlene, do we have beers? Oh no, no.
That'd be gave me some beers. Okay, good. I'm just checking to make sure. Okay.
Because it'd be fine. Oh yeah. We got the
[inaudible] you like that going? We're going to be smashing some of this,
like the beers. No don't ever give. He doesn't even deserve to have a beer.
You don't want some, a pecker is going to take her on juice too.
So I noticed as well that you also gave a bit tomb and eight. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. I actually would side more with gone on this one,
even though it did end kind of. Yeah. It wasn't the ending absolute,
but the show was really fun and the show was opening 10 out of 10
dude, 10 out of 10 opening. But soon the show VAT was just pure fun.
I dunno. Like it is good. It was, he was great.
It was one of the few death games that didn't feel like it was one, a,
a battle Royale rip-off because the problem with every death game anime is
that I feel, it feels like a, like a Virgin battle Royale. You know what I mean?
That's all y'all do there. I'm like, why would you,
why would I want to watch anything else? But it was just like,
it didn't try to pretend I wasn't a battle Royale rip off, but it just like,
it went off that, and it just was a hell of a lot of fun.
Now I think I gave it a lower score. I think when I first finished it,
I also gave him maybe like a seven or an eight,
but then I read the Munger and I was like, Oh yeah, give it to that.
Wasn't that great. I guess for some reason, like,
batoon has always been one of those shoes, like stuck with me. I don't know why.
Like I've always just wanted the season. I mean, I still,
I still think about it. Think about why it didn't have a season two.
Like I know Sydney read the manga.
She said the Mongo is also pretty good after the Monga among is way better.
I was actually good. Yeah. Okay. You gave her among us instead of 10.
So you did, to me, you all my brother,
because you gave gunk over tan, which I also agree with.